it should be something that people get
angry about like hey
you're
with definitions in order to pretend
that you're doing a good job
well said i couldn't say it better
anyway joining us now with more texas
senator ted cruz all right senator so
they don't want to admit the obvious
that this is a recession they're playing
word games
then we have more than doubled they want
to more than double the number of irs
agents uh that will mean more harassment
of the american people
and you look at that and we see these
massive increases on the middle class in
this country they're paying the bulk of
these new taxes i'm just trying to
understand why joe manchin uh not only
is going along with it but then lying
about it when he when he talks about it
on air look sean it's a it's a great
question joe rogan is exactly right the
white house has literally redefined
recession because the historical
definition has been two consecutive
quarters of gdp shrinking we have that
right now and so they just said never
mind words don't mean what they think so
suddenly recession is hunky-dory great
joe biden economic boom and they just
just are counting on the corrupt
corporate media to echo their lies you
look at this bill the schumer mansion
bill it is a terrible bill let me tell
you four consequences of this bill if it
passes number one 87 000 new irs agents
a massive influx and by the way these
agents are not there to go after the
billionaires the giant corporations
they're there to go after you they're
there to go after small businesses
they're there to descend upon
middle-class workers and audit the hell
out of you and the democrats believe if
we have this army of irs agents like a
swarm of locusts from washington it will
suddenly generate a lot of money and
they're probably right but i got to tell
you i've traveled all over texas all
over the country i've never heard one
human being say of all the things we
need in america we need more irs agents
that's what the democrats are promising
87 000 new ones the second big problem
manufacturing their so-called corporate
minimum tax
50 of the burden of that falls on
manufacturing what they're doing is
punishing companies for investing
capital in new manufacturing lines and
new truck lines in new car lines it is
devastating to workers the third group
that has heard is energy their new
energy taxes and fees in this if you're
pissed off at paying more to fill up
your gas tank guess what
schumer mansion makes it worse and
raises the cost of energy and fourth and
it's what larry kudlow just said
buried in the middle of this bill
are three little provisions that are
designed to repeal the supreme court's
decision in west virginia versus epa
west virginia versus epa they said look
the epa doesn't have the authority to
disregard the clean clean air act and
suddenly regulate carbon and drive up
the cost of energy for every american in
this country that decision was a
terrific victory for democracy
what schumer has convinced joe manchin
to do is put the word carbon into the cl
the clean air act the result of that
will be to bankrupt west virginia coal
miners i've never seen a west virginia
senator literally
undo the state of west virginia's
victory at the supreme court and
bankrupt one of the most important
industries in his entire state and yet
that's what we're facing right now
why would democrats heading into a
midterm election year think raising
taxes doubling the number of irs agents
is somehow a good they they consider
this if it happens a win for joe biden
in a win for democrats since when is
raising taxes and hiring irs agents a
win for any politician
well look many of these democrats are
hardcore ideological socialists they've
never met spending they don't like
they've never met death they don't like
that or met taxes they don't like their
answer you know it reminds me remember
that old saturday night live skit where
christopher walken is there there's a
band playing and his solution to
everything is more cowbell more cowbell
that's what the democrats are they want
more taxes more spending that's all they
know
and and what's amazing listen joe
mentions a good guy i like joe
but the degree to which he's been
snookered i i can't think of look as a
senator from texas if i signed on the
legislation bankrupting the oil and gas
industry that'd be really damn dumb he
just signed onto legislation bankrupting
the coal industry which is a huge
industry in the state of west virginia
and it doesn't make any sense and here's
why the democrats are doing this
they're counting on the corrupt
corporate media to stay silent to repeat
the white house's idiotic talking points
that this cures inflation look the cause
of the inflation is the democrats
massive spending their solution is spend
more and tax more it's like throwing
gasoline on a raging bonfire it will
only make inflation go up not down and
the media won't report on that
so they go to all these hostile regimes
from russia to iran to venezuela to
saudi arabia to opec and
it's okay if we import oil we just can't
produce it domestically even though we
end gas even though we have hundreds of
years of supplies were worth we don't
have to beg texas for example i think
you guys would willingly produce
everything
and then they're pushing electric cars
which cost about 20 grand more than a
gasoline-powered car uh that to build
that battery you got to mine cobalt and
nickel and and manganese and and other
minerals using big equipment that uses
diesel and disrupt mother earth to get
it and then when you actually plug in
to charge your battery uh 88
of the grid is uh gas and coal so you're
still using gas and coal to power the
electric vehicle how does that make
sense to you
look it's it's fundamentally deceptive
it's dishonest it doesn't make any sense
when biden was elected the average price
of gasoline was two dollars and 38 cents
a gallons it has doubled since then and
that's not an accident they've attacked
u.s energy production you're right
they're encouraging iran and venezuela
are enemies to produce because they
don't want american energy and it is
hurting consumers and i got to say their
transportation secretary pete
butterjudge was very honest he said the
pain is the point the more we drive up
your cost of the pump the more what
you'll do more pain the more you just
sell your suburban and buy a prius
that's not what the american people want
uh well you got to pay 20 grand more up
front and you also got to you know dig
out a lot of minerals and you're still
using the electric grid to charge the
electric vehicle all right that's that's
what i think is built with chinese slave
labor unbelievable all right thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else